blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
davidpackman so yesterday I talked about
the death of Colin Powell and we talked
about the political side of it Colin
Powell a republican who yes in his later
years spoke out against anti-muslim
rhetoric and condemned the xenophobia
and the nonsense of Donald Trump and
Trump's followers was not a trump
supporting Republican but also was one
of the most Sinister figures in the sale
of the Iraq War to the American people
and the International Community with
faulty intelligence back in 2003 and we
looked at clips of that and we talked
about the political and we also talked
about the medical Colin Powell was
vaccinated
he was 84 years old died of coveted
complications and I mentioned yesterday
that many anti-vaxxers would use this
and point to it and say see there's no
point in getting vaccinated ignoring of
course that the data shows
overwhelmingly that those who die are
not vaccinated and in addition to that
in the hours after we published
yesterday's clip
we learned that Colin Powell was
severely immunocompromised had
Parkinson's as well as a type of blood
cancer called multiple myeloma which is
a big being in treatment for multiple
myeloma is a significant
immunocompromising
circumstance for an individual but it
didn't matter the anti-vax stuff
exploded and it wasn't just the usual
suspect it was even Fox News daytime
reporters pushing this stuff the
anti-vaxxers are foaming at the mouth
using Colin Powell's death while
vaccinated to attack vaccines and to
attack vaccine requirements so we're
going to go over this today
but it's important to say again
Colin Powell was not just a random guy
who was vaccinated and died which can
happen we have significant protection
against severe disease and death from
the vaccines but with a planet of seven
to eight billion people you're going to
have some random seemingly healthy
people who are vaccinated and die that
doesn't mean that we ignore the bigger
statistics but Colin Powell was not just
a random guy he was not even just a
random 84 year old guy who was
vaccinated and died of covid he was an
84 year old
immunocompromised man who died despite
being vaccinated had cancer and had
Parkinson's which significantly affects
your immune system but the anti-vaxxers
want to pretend see the vaccine does
nothing for anyone anybody could die
it's just chance Fox News host will Kane
went on a rant yesterday morning saying
fully vaccinated people are being
hospitalized and dying and it's just we
we can't trust anybody he brought up
covet look this day will be a day for
many things for remembering the man for
remembering the leader that was lost
it's also a day to understand the
implication on everyday Americans and
and the reports are he died from
complications of covet the family has
made a point in their post on Facebook
this morning that Colin Powell was fully
vaccinated and As Americans out there
wonder what lies ahead for them and they
they search and they need truth moving
forward we're seeing data from across
the world we're seeing data from Europe
from the United Kingdom the fully
vaccinated people are being hospitalized
and fully vaccinated people are dying
from covet and here we have a very high
profile example that is going to require
more truth more truth from our
government far now of course there's no
lack of Truth the truth is you're
overwhelmingly less likely to die of
covet if you're vaccinated colon he's
straight up saying this is anecdotal
thinking he's straight up saying this
case shows that we're not getting enough
truth
this case doesn't change the truth which
is the overwhelming uh uh majority of
those who are dying are unvaccinated
even as the country is more and more
vaccinated here's another similar
example this one is from Fox and Friends
playing a similar game there will also
be conversations about the fact that he
was fully vaccinated according to his
family and he died from complications
from covet we are beginning to see
statistics like this grow in frequency
we know that the vaccine does Wane over
time and its ability to protect you from
not just transmission infection but from
severe complications and hospitalization
and obviously death as well we know that
it wanes and we know that it's beginning
to spill over covid into the vaccinated
population again Colin Powell in the
direct age demographic that suffers the
most from complications from covid but I
think everyone watching needs to be
aware of limitations and protections
yeah limitation you are always better
off with the protection of the vaccine
that's the reality and then we'll we'll
follow up on this later
um Fox news reporter John Roberts
tweeted Powell's death was evidence of
the waning efficacy tweeting the fact
that Colin Powell died from a
breakthrough covet infection raises new
concerns about how effective vaccines
are long term no it doesn't and he
subsequently deleted this tweet he
subsequently deleted this tweet as
Mother Jones has been reporting major
news outlets ran headlines about this
um without acknowledging that Colin
Powell was immunocompromised with
multiple conditions but talking about
him being vaccinated if you're going to
talk about him being vaccinated you've
got to talk about the other side as well
New York Times Colin Powell first black
National Security adviser died at 84 of
covet he was fully vaccinated family
said right but you've you've got to tell
both sides of that MSNBC Colin Powell
dies from covet complications Powell was
fully vaccinated Newsweek former U.S
Secretary of State Colin Powell dies
from covet complications was fully
vaccinated
Colin Powell said in an announcement on
social media he was fully vaccinated if
you're going to do that you should
really say fully vaccinated and severely
immunocompromised it would be
irresponsible not to or skip saying both
skip saying both if you want here's Dr
Zeke Emmanuel
discrediting the idea that Colin
Powell's death
means the vaccines aren't working and he
mentions Powell's risk factors take a
look Colin Powell had three important
risk factors for covet one is his age 84
he's at the very high end and we know
those people are much more vulnerable
second as you point out he had cancer
and third he's a man and men are at much
higher risk of dying especially in his
age category 58 of deaths in those
people 65 to 84 are male even though
they make up a minority of that age
group when it comes to multiple myeloma
it's a cancer of the cells the B cells
in the immune system that produce
antibodies so they don't produce
effective antibodies and they grow and
grow
and when you treat someone uh for
multiple myeloma it does suppress the
immune system so he was
immunocompromised okay so that's as if
we needed more medical experts telling
us what has become obvious over the year
and a half of the pandemic so we are now
going to talk separately about
specifically Tucker Carlson's dog and
pony show that he did in reaction to
this because it's particularly
disastrous and particularly weaponized
so uh Colin Powell died of coveted
complications severely immunocompromised
multiple myeloma Parkinson's and
vaccinated 84 years old that's what we
know
Fox News and others doing their sort of
soft anti-vax type stuff but Tucker
Carlson really going fully fully in on
it uh as Media Matters reports Tucker
Carlson claims Colin Powell's death
proves quote you've been lied to about
vaccine Effectiveness you've been lied
to now of course
a vaccinated death in an 84 year old
immunocompromised individual doesn't
disprove anything about vaccines doesn't
say it doesn't indicate anybody has lied
people lie all the time about all sorts
of things Colin Powell dying is not
proof uh Colin Powell dying is not proof
that anybody in particular is lying so
let's take a look at this video clip
here is Tucker Carlson let's just get
right into it because the the we have to
start there to understand what the point
is that's being made here a lot has
changed in the years since and that's
one of the reasons that Colin Powell's
death tonight is so poignant
like almost everyone his age Colin
Powell was fully vaccinated against
covid and yet according to his family
and doctors Colin Powell died of covet
of course that fact does not make his
death any less sad nor is it unusual
many thousands of vaccinated Americans
have died of covet former CDC director
Robert so first of all understand when
we talk about the data thousands of
Americans dying of covid out of 700 plus
thousand deaths and overwhelmingly the
deaths are the unvaccinated you if you
don't understand that data Tucker's
comment is extraordinarily confusing and
a lot of the people you know Tucker does
that confused face during his show many
of his audience members have that same
face they're just as confused edfield
announced just today that about 40
percent of all recent coveted deaths in
the state of Maryland for example are
among those who have had both shots now
that's another deceptive thing imagine a
100 vaccinated country in a 100 percent
vaccinated country 100 of deaths would
be among vaccinated people why is
Maryland important Maryland is highly
highly vaccinated so you you have to
understand that's a mathematical reality
as well and there's a specific reason
why Tucker talks about Maryland
so what does that tell you exactly what
tells you you've been lied to vaccines
may be highly useful for some people but
across the population they do not solve
covet now that's two different things
the first of all you've been lied to
well not what's the lie that you've been
told number two vaccines are useful at
every population at reducing risk of
death you might have one population with
a higher risk and one population with a
low risk at all populations you have a
lower risk of death when vaccinated
that's not speculation it is an
observable fact that's not true people
who've been fully vaccinated can still
get the virus true you can still
transmit the virus to others true and
they can still die from covet that
dramatically lower rates when Powell is
hardly the only example of that so the
question is why are they telling us
otherwise
and the answer is simple they're telling
us that to divide us from each other
that is completely untrue I mean this
this is you have to understand the
motive here for Tucker who's almost
certainly fully vaccinated Etc and by
the way works for Fox News which has one
of the strictest vaccine mandates we've
heard about for any large corporation
the whole point here is
get people afraid
get people angry afraid and angry and at
the end of the broadcast Tucker Carlson
casually mentions oh okay I didn't
mention that Colin Powell was suffering
from a number of health problems almost
like an aside he talked about being pal
being fully vaccinated didn't mention
the health conditions just kind of drops
it in at the very end of the show yeah
apparently Drury thanks so much for
coming on I appreciate St Luke's
Hospital in my pleasure appreciate it
so the beginning of the show we told you
about Colin Powell we left out that
Colin Powell was suffering from a number
of different health problems but of
course that's the point the point of
vaccinating the vulnerable is so people
with other underlying health problems
won't die of covet
but unfortunately that didn't work in
the case of General Powell it didn't
work for many thousands of other
Americans and of course that's the point
we're making in the first place yeah and
what's funny is it he's acting like this
is an important point that nobody else
is making
no one ever said the vaccines are 100
effective and when you talk about
population level statistics and you see
the death rate among the unvaccinated
versus the death rate among the
vaccinated the one story of Colin Powell
although Tucker is making a lot out of
it
although Fox News and others are making
a lot out of it is not actually
instructive in any way it doesn't prove
anybody lied
it doesn't prove that vaccines don't
work it doesn't prove any of it but
Tucker's audience is primed to accept
this stuff Hook Line and Sinker we'll
talk a little more about the data later
in the show you can send me your
thoughts find me on Twitter at dpacman
today is the David Pacman show live
viewer Town Hall it'll be at 6 PM
eastern time today Tuesday October 19th
it will be streaming on our Pac-Man Live
YouTube channel that's not the main
YouTube channel it's the second YouTube
channel Pac-Man Live we'll see you at 6
pm and we'll be back in just a minute
here
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the David packman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app I just
listened to this is your mind on Plants
by the great Michael pollen super
interesting the history of caffeine and
so many other things blinkist has you
covered on podcast two blinkist takes
long episodes of popular podcasts and
distills them into audio you can listen
to and 15 minutes with blinkist you can
become knowledgeable about so many
different things you can have
conversations with people about more
topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded try blink is for free and
get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com
davidpackman the link is down below
all right so let's do um one more sort
of awkward moment in the aftermath to
the Colin Powell death that we reported
on yesterday I mentioned in the first
segment how Fox news reporter John
Roberts tweeted something completely
insane about the death and vaccines and
then quickly deleted it well it got even
weirder when then Fox News brought on a
guest to talk about people that are
reacting and saying things that are
wrong and John Roberts was sitting there
very awkwardly as Dr Nicole safier was
essentially describing what John Roberts
said without actually naming him so
let's let's kind of like refresh this
entire thing uh John Roberts tweeted
yesterday after the death of Colin
Powell was announced the fact that Colin
Powell died from a breakthrough covet
infection raises new concerns about how
effective vaccines are long term now
that's not true
we knew that immunocompromised people
like Colin Powell would Mount Less on
average of an immune response we know
that the older you are in Colin Powell
was 84 the more likely you are to die
from covid
um
obviously that goes down with being
vaccinated but vaccinated populations
the older you are the more likely you
are to die from covet and unvaccinated
as well it's sort of a distribution that
that is like that so John Roberts
quickly deleted this tweet so then Fox
News brings on Dr Nicole safier
and John Roberts is on screen and Nicole
safer says this doesn't mean the
vaccines don't work this stuff has to
stop a lot of people are spreading
nonsense and John Roberts looking very
uncomfortable because she doesn't name
him but he had just gotten done tweeting
this nonsense and then deleting it
something that you want to get out there
in the wake of Colin Powell's death that
you want people to know because
obviously there's a lot of information
to take in on this final thought from
you
well I can tell you Sandra you know it's
very it's very upsetting to see that
people taking
um Colin Powell's death and using it as
the vaccine didn't work oh well that's
exactly what John Roberts did and now
he's going to sit there and listen to
you this is a very specific situation
and one to use someone's death to try
and make a point that really doesn't
carry a lot of weight to it oh that's
exactly what John Roberts was doing he
was trying to make a point that carries
no weight using Colin Powell's death is
very frustrating but I can tell you that
this was a very specific situation you
had an elderly gentleman I know that
people don't like that word but at the
age of 84 he was already vulnerable for
covet 19. and then you add a cancer of
the blood and he is the most vulnerable
when it comes to covet 19. our thoughts
was his family for sure at this moment
after learning of his death this morning
yeah yeah John Roberts oh yeah very much
yes of course well he's the guy who just
did exactly that he looked uncomfortable
and he should look uncomfortable and it
is it is an instructive lesson in if we
already know that while the vaccine
reduces your risk of hospitalization and
death dramatically it is not 100
and then one well-known person dies it
actually changes nothing it it changes
nothing about our overall understanding
of the vaccine's effectiveness it's just
we know the name of this person
it's a well-known person that's what it
changes and these I don't know if
they're opportunists I don't know if
they're simply ignorant I don't know if
they're bad people who use this as uh
they see it as opening the door to tweet
exactly what John Roberts tweeted which
he was then later shamed or someone
called him and said you really should
pull that down uh it is not serious
thinking these are not serious
contributions to our understanding of
how vaccination works and they shouldn't
be considered that okay this is very
very interesting this is in a way kind
of like a Joe Rogan covid part two this
right winger Dennis Prager
is known for Prager University which is
a YouTube channel that puts out a kind
of right-wing analyzes and
interpretations of uh the world we've
heard that there are some teachers who
even play these prageru videos in
classrooms which is wholly inappropriate
Dennis Prager is sort of like this Uber
right-winger he's never seen a
right-wing position he doesn't like and
he has been
um saying a lot of things that don't
make sense about covid all along Dennis
Prager now has coronavirus okay so he's
doing his show from home and in this
clip there's a few things we're going to
look at Dennis Prater has been
downplaying covet all along he says in
this clip he wanted to get covered in
order to develop natural immunity and he
tells us everything's fine everything's
no big deal but he is taking five
medications including ones that are not
proven to do anything for covid and it
reminded me of the Joe Rogan thing where
Joe Rogan also said let's listen I'm
fine I felt terrible for a day or two
but I'm taking in Rogan's case I think
it was six medications plus supplements
and vitamins but this is no big deal now
of course our question was it would you
do that for the flu because if you
wouldn't then clearly this is more
serious than the flu which many of these
folks deny so let's just get into the
clip there's a lot here there's a lot
here and we're going to talk in detail
about all of this okay everybody all
good I'm broadcasting from my home right
foreign
so by the way what he did there was he
had a he has a cough button
if you're watching he just let out a
horrifying cough but it wasn't audible
right right at the top here
because I'm not going into the station
as I have coveted I came I was tested
positive last week
and I have been
steadily improving
at no point was I in danger of
hospitalization
I have received monoclonal
antibodies okay
that's regeneron I have of course for
years a year and a half not years I've
been taking
hydroxychloroquine from the beginning
with zinc
I've taken z-pack the
erythromycin right
as the zelinko protocol would have it I
have taken Ivermectin okay
I have done what a person should do
if one is not going to get vaccinated
it is infinitely preferable to have
natural immunity than vaccine immunity
that has not been demonstrated
and that is what I hoped for the entire
time
hence I so uh
engaged with strangers constantly
hugging them taking photos with them
knowing that I was in making myself very
susceptible to getting covered
which is indeed as bizarre as it sounded
what I wanted wow
in the hope that I would achieve natural
immunity and be taken care of by
Therapeutics that is exactly what has
happened it should have happened to the
great majority of Americans
the number of deaths in this country
owing to covid is a scandal
one day will be clear to America so I
guess he's saying the covet death toll
is exaggerated or something like that
now the truth is if we had taken a
so-called herd immunity approach like
get as many people infected as possible
the estimates are that the death toll
would be in the millions already rather
than the hundreds of thousands but where
do I want to focus today
do you take five medications for
something that's no big deal do you take
five medications include I mean these
are some some of these are serious
medications do you take this for the flu
do you take this for a cold and clearly
you don't meaning you are conceding that
this is different and more serious so
let's talk about them monoclonal
antibodies okay monoclonal antibodies
appear to be effective at reducing
hospitalization rate and the progression
of severe disease and death when a
patient has mild to moderate covet in
the most serious covid it's not clear
that the monoclonal antibodies help but
in mild to moderate covid it does seem
to prevent the progression to more
severe covid
uh so monoclonal antibodies yes that's
uh approved by emergency use remember a
standard which many of these folks say
is not sufficient for the vaccine but
they'll gladly take the monoclonal
antibodies under emergency use
authorization
um azithromycin the z-pack okay that's a
antibiotic now he calls it erythromycin
that's a different one this is
azithromat Azithromycin the uh data on
azithromycin for covid the overall
quality of evidence is low to very low
with a conclusion that azithromycin does
not result in Superior clinical
Improvement in covid patients relative
to Placebo azithromycin is generally
well tolerated and safe to use which we
know it's an antibiotic that's been
around for a long time does not seem to
do anything for covid but he's taking it
anyway okay
hydroxychloroquine now there are
instances of lots of things that you can
find with hydroxychloroquine you can
find individual so-called studies often
with sample sizes in the teens or or
dozens that may say it might work the
big picture is that the current body of
evidence does not show a clinical
benefit for prophylactic
hydroxychloroquine that's what Dennis
Prager says he has been doing is he's
been taking it prophylactically for a
year and a half
and there is a higher risk of Adverse
Events compared to a placebo or compared
to no prophylaxis so hydroxychloroquine
not unproven doesn't doesn't know
evidence it works Ivermectin okay there
is some uncertainty about whether
Ivermectin compared with a placebo or
the standard of care
reduces or increases mortality in
moderately ill hospitalized patients and
many of the studies have a bias as well
as in Precision it's not even clear a
lot of the studies being pointed to are
acceptable there have been multiple
papers on Ivermectin withdrawn after
pre-print because they were not
rigorously done
it does not appear as though Ivermectin
uh helps treat covid he's taking zinc
now zinc okay
um high dose zinc has been studied
supplementation high dose zinc it's been
studied for colds it's been studied and
thought about for flu with covid there
is no evidence right now that there was
a significant reduction in the duration
of symptoms for people who are
supplementing zinc some studies with a
placebo arm specifically on older
patients suggest hospitalized coveted
patients seem to survive a little bit
longer with zinc it's important to know
a lot of older folks are zinc deficient
so it could be a vitamin D type
situation it's worthy of a study right
now there's no causal Association found
with zinc on covid
um and we can't say that it actually
helps so what what it might be with zinc
is that you need to treat a ton a ton a
ton of people with super high dose zinc
uh and have a lot of a lot of people in
that population be zinc deficient to
then find someone who actually survives
all together because of the zinc we just
don't know it's certainly not clear
right now that there's any causal links
so that's what Prager is taking four of
the five things he's taking aren't shown
to actually do anything for covid and
remember this is something that's not
serious anyway it's it's something
that's not serious anyway as far as he
and many many others have said so very
confusing and by the way I've gone
around hugging people and blah blah blah
blah blah who knows uh what the uh
follow-on effects of that are and it
certainly doesn't seem considerate to
anybody else to be doing that in the
middle of a global pandemic so that's
Dennis Prager a man that many people see
as a great thinker as a great speaker as
a great
um uh uh almost like a mage of some sort
there are people who worship this guy
and this is what he's doing taking five
medications four of which are unproven
for something that wasn't serious anyway
very very strange stuff and we'll have
more on this on our Instagram which you
can find at davidpackman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
it's great to welcome back to the
program today Bill share who is
contributor to the Washington monthly
and Real Clear Politics also host of The
History Podcast when America worked uh
Bill always great having you on always
great to talk to you so uh I'm trying to
understand
different individuals motivations in
either being in favor of or against the
in various iterations of the
infrastructure proposals that we've been
seeing now for for several months let's
kind of start with what's been more in
the news which is maybe Joe manchin Joe
manchin and and Kirsten Cinema when I
step back and think about West Virginia
you know 47th in healthcare uh very
close to 50th if not 50th in education
very poor infrastructure would be a
place that would really benefit from
from exactly this it would seem like hey
his constituents would reward him for
getting them some money
and then the story that's now floated
around is well look at his uh income
from fossil fuel companies that would be
hurt by the climate piece of this is it
is it as simple as a follow the money
type thing
well I I don't want to play mind reader
uh and I understand people wanting to
connect dots and everyone's welcome to
you know have their own theories sure uh
but you know people went into this year
thinking
oh Mansion likes the posture but this is
essentially a populist State and so
he'll do the populist thing yeah and I
was not doing the populist thing it's
about coming with fresh theories I think
we look at mansion's longer record in
politics from those very early days in
West Virginia he has always been a
business friendly Centrist that has
always been his thing it's not new and
why he's a business really Centrist
you're welcome to have your own theories
about that but that just seems to be the
case and
uh you at the end of the day if you want
this bill to pass you need his vote
however annoying it is to get that vote
it is needed and I think this is also
true for Cinema
I think the strategy of brown being them
publicly
and challenging their political Acumen
accusing them of corruption it may all
be true but it's not getting you their
vote they're not being shamed into
moving off their position so I think a
different attack needs to be taken if
they're if you're going to get to 50
which may be happening that we're seeing
the conversation starting to materialize
now yeah you and I both I think tweeted
um a disfavor about following Kirsten
Cinema into the bathroom
um and I as I said you know the what I
said on my show was
maybe you could make the case that the
bathroom is the only place where she
might be confronted by an opposing view
it seems contrary to reality and thus
that is a tactic doesn't seem to me to
be particularly productive but what what
can be done to effectively pressure a
lot of these folks who you know the the
boaters uh swam up to the yacht of Joe
manchin and uh it wasn't particularly
inspiring the things that he said I mean
like what actually works to pressure
these people uh from from an individual
voter standpoint yeah I mean you know
different tactics work on different
people there's not a one-size-fits-all
here but but at minimum
for the last several weeks and months
people have tried confrontation people
have tried getting to their personal
spaces people have tried haranguing them
as being on the take and not only have
they not moved they seem to have you
know dug in their heels and even at the
precise moment when progressives thought
they were gaining more leverage by
blocking the bipartisan infrastructure
bill that you know Mansion spearheaded
Cinema essentially wrote it's it's
called Cinema Portman for Pete's sake
yeah uh thinking well if we hold that
hostage what's prize to them they'll
have to come they'll have to come around
almost immediately that price tag on
build back better went down by nearly 50
percent right uh so the tactics just
aren't working and so I I just think the
entire approach of treating them as
effectively adversaries people who are
not Progressive who don't see the world
the way we do and need to be dragged and
doing the right thing that approach
isn't working I think you want to get
the temperature down you want to get
into the same room with them and try to
talk them and figure out where is the
common ground it has to be I mean if
there's no common ground there's no
Common Ground I think there is some
common ground you got to find where that
is and not make it into a grudge match
because a grudge match isn't working in
progressives favorites yeah I do think
that part of what makes it difficult is
it seems as though Joe manchin is very
dishonest and what I mean by that is for
a while he was saying the problem was
the price tag as you mentioned
iterations of this have seen a much
reduced price tag and now he doesn't
like it for different reasons so part of
it is is maybe maybe common ground is
the way to describe that but also moving
goal posts seems to be a real problem
here
well you both mansion and Cinema can be
I mean Manchester can use a lot of word
salad which makes them inscrutable in
certain ways yeah and Cinema is very
quiet which makes her unscrutable and
this frustrates the hell out of
progressives
I think it's a negotiating topic is
working very well for them everyone's
chasing their vote right we're throwing
things at them to figure out what's
going to make them happy so they're in
the driver's seat uh I don't think it's
fair to say Mansion has moved the goal
post because he has been consistent on a
number of things you look at that piece
of paper that he signed with Chuck
Schumer back in July now granted this
wasn't known to the rest of us at the
time but he communicated this to his
majority leader of all the things that
he um wanted that he was comfortable
with and essentially by Omission what he
was not comfortable with uh that's all
been pretty consistent he's been saying
for a long time he doesn't like this
Clean Energy payment program which is
was intend to be the center because of
the climate section of the bill that's
not new uh so I think he's always had a
combination of price tag concerns and
substantive concerns uh and people have
tried to you know grind him down instead
of accepting that he holds a determining
vote and so what what are his concerns
de facto become your concerns you need
to resolve those concerns to get a bill
there's many progressives who every time
this happens say we got a primary Joe
manchin and whenever that happens I tend
to think well I don't know that if a
further left Democrat wins the primary
they actually win the general senate
election in West Virginia that might
lead to replacing a Democrat with a
republican I think we need to be solving
this you solve 50 50 by taking some
existing Republican seats and turning
them to democratic seats what's your
general perspective on this idea of
primary Joe manchin even as as a
pressure tactic to get him to be scared
in some way well he's been primaried and
he's unfazed so I mean West Virginia is
just too red the fact that Joe mancha is
there at all is a gift for Democrats
they should be they would not have a
majority without Joe manchin right now
it would be Mitch mcconnellson and we've
been talking about a multi-trillion
dollar bill at all uh so Mansion shrugs
that off very gleefully now Cinema is a
different story yes uh uh Cinema seems
to have a theory of the case that she
doesn't care either if she gets
primaried that her path of success is
you know is maverickiness mccain-like
um uh independence from party leadership
and even though those primary threats
are more pronounced uh and are very
vocalized right now again she is not
budging so I understand worth trying it
out is to give it my get her Running
Scared but she's not Running Scared uh
so I mean it may be by 2024 when she's
up she'll lose that primary I can't say
I think she will probably survive a
primary it's very unusual for an
incumbent to be ousted in the primary
particularly in ideological reasons
usually if it happens it's for a scandal
reason uh so the Arizona is still pretty
purple it's not hard blue and they're
probably a lot of people in Arizona even
who are Democrats who say electability
comes first so I would still put my
money on Cinema surviving but it's
really not a slam dunk uh but
nevertheless she's not being cowed by
that pressure tactic what is going to or
let's we'll work backwards does this
bill's passage or failure affect
Democrats in 2022 is it the type of
thing that voters would actually vote
one way or the other on does Joe Biden
getting something else big done impact
Democrats in 2022 what does matter
looking at the midterms well there's two
ways to look at 2022 one is Democrats
going to lose no matter what because the
midterm president's party they always
lose something the margins are so narrow
they're just the tiniest tiniest bit of
something means it's all over so get
what you can while you can and don't
even worry about the politics right one
school of thought it's not illegitimate
um the other is you know even though it
doesn't usually happen it can happen
it's happened three times in the past
you know I think I think post
reconstruction uh that the president's
party has gained a few seats and I think
a fourth time when they just lost like
very very little enough that Democrats
could actually survive this time around
uh and when those things happen it's
almost always because there's some kind
of crisis
and the president's party is seen as
managing that Christ as well
and so the usual Dynamic of the
president's party's Coalition
splintering because of the natural
realities of governing trade-offs
compromises imperfections unfulfilled
aspirations and dreams things that you
know deplete some of your base or make
some people in the middle peel off while
your opposition is Unified against
whatever it is the president's party is
doing that's the reason why the
president's party usually loses uh so if
Democrats can't pass build back better
at all or if it's reduced to such a nub
that it makes people some people unhappy
that makes some people on the base
displeased you know even if it's a good
general election politics it's good for
the center if that base is unhappy you
know if any if any faction is unhappy
that's bad for the midterms you need
full Unity to overcome the historical
Trend uh so that's another reason why
it's not good for Democrats to be in
this tug of war right now where
someone's gonna feel bad had regardless
of the outcome you want everyone to feel
good about the outcome even though it's
almost certainly going to be some kind
of compromise what about something like
the Afghanistan withdrawal which by the
way I wasn't remain completely in favor
of and believe it would have been just
as if not more chaotic under Donald
Trump but that ultimately it's the right
decision when that took place in August
into September there was a lot of talk
of this will torpedo the midterms for
Democrats and I really really didn't see
it for two reasons one that it really
was a Biden thing and of course it can
affect the midterms we're talking about
that but number two uh it just seems
like it's it there's enough time between
then and the midterms and the relatively
short memories of Voters struck me as I
don't think Afghanistan is going to play
a factor in the midterms what do you
think I mean I I wrote a piece to that
effect at the Washington monthly at the
time when I with the caveat of some kind
of 9 11 occurring sometimes have
terrorist attack on our soil launched
from Afghanistan because a terrorist
outfit was able to regroup under the
current circumstances that would be you
know obviously bad for people's lives
and bad for Democrats politically uh
outside of that I think we're already
seeing Afghanistan Fading Into the
background of politics
having said that
Biden has not had
a single day
with a good headline
since early August when the Afghanistan
withdrawal occurred it means if it's
Afghanistan it's covet Delta vario it's
not covid it's something on the border
if it's not saying the Border it's the
infrastructure bill being blocked the
instructor build being blocked it's that
build back better is is in limbo or
there's a debt limit drama you know it's
always something yeah and there hasn't
been a good day
uh and Afghanistan was just the first
time when there was an obviously bad day
where people sort of saying wait a
second maybe these guys don't know what
they're doing maybe they're not perfect
maybe they're not the most competent
operation in the universe uh you can fix
that with some wins but putting some
points on the board uh which is why I
wonder I mean I can't I certainly can't
predict this and it's not the way it
panned out you know two and a half weeks
ago but we are coming up on another
deadline on October 31st where uh Nancy
Pelosi said we need to pass the
bipartisan infrastructure bill by this
date because the highway trust fund is
going to expire now she said the same
thing a month ago and what happened a
month ago was that Progressive said we
don't care we're not going to give you
the votes Biden came to the house and
said look these have to be done at the
same time uh and then people scrambled
and passed a highway trust fund
extension for 30 days and progresses
essentially who said this is this isn't
a real deadline because you can push
that off they were proven correct
however you can only push off that
Highway trust fund deadline if
Republicans in the Senate agree that's
not a it's not a Reconciliation vote
that's a regular order vote uh
Republicans did that last month because
they said this isn't this isn't cost any
extra money there's enough money in the
kitty for the federal government to pay
out what's needed for Road and Transit
projects for States and localities but
that may not be the case two weeks from
now so if it's a real hard deadline
especially one of the negative headlines
the past two weeks has been the supply
chain issue yes uh buying is saying he's
trying to fix that he knows it's a
serious problem and over the Long Haul
we need to pass the bipartisan
infrastructure bill because it invests
money in ports and Freight rail so he's
connecting those two things right now uh
do they really want to have the highway
trust fund
you know lapse
so no money's paid out to States and
localities for infrastructure projects
indefinitely
while there is a supply chain crisis
going on right uh might Biden come back
to the house in two weeks and say look
we're in a jam here people you know
we're not getting anywhere
um build back better we got a supply
chain problem my polls are in the dumps
uh we're trying to be the infrastructure
party we can't be having infrastructure
projects get throttled over the or I
mean that I mean it wouldn't happen in
instant it wouldn't be like all of a
sudden everyone drops their their
jackhammers uh but States no college
would not know over time if the money
was coming and that would cause a lot of
disruptions uh and people would vocally
complain do you want those kind of
complaints happening at the stay and
local level uh while we've had months
and months of inactivity from Democrats
might Biden come in and put his thumb on
the scale the other way and say I need
you on this vote now I need you to suck
it up and pass this vote not predicting
it I'm saying those factors are in the
mix and one other factor in the mix I
should add God Virginia
November 2nd is the Virginia
gubernatorial election Terry McCall the
Democratic nominee is saying I'm sick of
these Democrats in Washington not
getting stuff done we need this
infrastructure bill passed and some
people fear if McCall loses then
everything's going to fall apart that
Mansion Cinema will be even harder to
get and harder to couch out to
progresses because they'll say that it's
it's your intransigence that led to This
calamity in Virginia uh somebody might
say it's your entrance you dance because
you wouldn't do things our way and just
be hard and hard to come to come to
terms so what all that come together and
make Democrats suck it up on the
infrastructure Bill not predicting but
those are different factors that were
not present a month ago so wait are you
predicting or not I'm not I'm not sure
no I'm kidding now
far
but it might still conclude yeah yeah he
doesn't want to be a source of party
disunity right no I'm kidding I'm
hesitant to push one faction over the
other yep um by doing a different set of
factors than you did a month ago without
a doubt without a doubt Bill share
contributor to the Washington monthly
and Real Clear Politics host of The
History Podcast when America worked Bill
always a pleasure same here take care
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show alright
let's do a lesson here in dishonesty
propaganda lying with Statistics a bunch
of other stuff I have a Graphic that I'm
going to show you that I believe is at
least a top Contender for the most
dishonest graphic ever shown on Fox News
and it's dishonest probably in three to
four different ways okay here's the
graphic as you can see it's from Sean
Hannity's Fox news program last night
this is really instructive in terms of
propaganda in line with Statistics the
graphic is part of a segment wanting to
blame Joe Biden for covet deaths it was
a segment about how bad Joe Biden is and
of course the hypocrisy is incredible
because these very same people didn't
really care about the covet death
numbers when Donald Trump was President
then in fact they went out of their way
to apologize for Trump and claim he's
doing a great job and covid's not that
serious and all of that stuff so the
claim here is is just comparing covet
deaths in 2020
to covet deaths in 2021 and making it
seem that Joe Biden is worse than Trump
now what the graphic says or shows is
that in 2020 352
000 people died of covid whereas in 2021
372
000 people died of covet so the point
here is 2020 under Trump 352 000 kova
deaths 2021 not even in the full year
under Biden more deaths by about 20 000.
so let's consider the ways that this is
dishonest and I'm not doing this to
score points for one team or another
it's about understanding whether you
were being honestly given information
and what you should deduce from it so
first of all
uh Donald Trump was president the first
three weeks of 2021 during those first
three weeks of 2021 about 72 000
Americans died of covet so right off the
bat despite this graphic
of these deaths 424
000 happened when Trump was president
and 300 000 happened while Joe Biden was
President so like without even debating
the merits of whether this entire
exercise makes any sense the by
President Donald Trump actually was
president during 124 000 more coveted
deaths than Joe Biden this is actually
pretty dumb I'm not going to even say
this is a this is an intelligent thing
to do there are lots of people for
example that died in February when Biden
was president
but who caught the virus when Trump was
president
who gets the blame for that death it's
sort of a weird metric it's not very
useful but by the standards of the
people making the graphics it could say
424
000 uh dead under Trump 300 000 dead
under Biden that paints a completely
different picture that's layer of
dishonesty number one
second layer of dishonesty the deaths
didn't really start in the United States
until April of 2020. okay uh in the last
10 days of March 2020 we saw deaths go
up so even in comparing these numbers
and the thinking about them as Trump
versus Biden Trump kind of had a freebie
for January of 2020 February of 2020
March most of March of 2020. now some
will say David there were deaths in
those months we just didn't know that
they were covered yet they were called
pneumonia or something else that's the
point is they're not in the numbers okay
so in the Biden category they're
including the first three weeks of 2021
when Biden wasn't even president plus
more months overall since we have about
nine weeks left this year and Trump
really only had eight months worth of
deaths in 2020. so that's another level
of dishonesty for what is a very stupid
exercise all right that's another one
but now let me get to the really
dishonest part of this
the deaths even in 2021 even today
are mostly overwhelmingly the
unvaccinated who are mostly Trump
supporting Republicans so is it really
Joe Biden's fault that Trump supporters
have been bamboozled into not wanting
the vaccine by other right-wingers and
they are dying for me that's the real
dishonesty here and of course there's
this highly contagious Delta variant
which plagued the planet in 2021 that's
not Trump's fault it's not Joe Biden's
fault although more vaccination would
have slowed down the mutation as Vincent
reckon yellow and others have told us so
a ton of this stuff it's like it's kind
of ticky tacky as we might say in sports
well there's these three weeks and uh in
January when when Trump was still
president but they're you know when do
the deaths really become under the watch
of one president versus when the deaths
happen when the person got sick it's
tough It's nebulous it's not
particularly meaningful comparing 11
months for Biden
to eight months for Trump that's also
dishonest but the real dishonesty is
that they do all this stuff while
ignoring that the deaths are higher
because of right-wing anti-vaxxers and
it's more right-wingers than left
Wingers all along who were participating
in behaviors that spread the virus and
also this is a subtle attack on
vaccination we shouldn't ignore that we
are far more vaccinated now than in 2020
and that was the theme yesterday on Fox
News in part thanks to the death of
Colin Powell who as we already talked
about was fully vaccinated but 84 years
old
immunocompromised Parkinson's cancer so
it's incredibly dishonest it's important
to spot the stuff and sometimes there's
kind of two analyzes that need to be
done
one is we just look at the numbers and
we think through okay wait so who was
president in 2020 how many death okay
let's think about that when did Death
start to even be counted in 2020 uh we
we have to think about all that but then
there's the big dishonesty which is the
ways in which these numbers are being
used to make political statements that
don't actually follow from the numbers
and ignore who it is that's keeping
people from being vaccinated in the
first place so up there up there one of
the most dishonest Graphics I've seen on
Fox News when you really break it down
and think it through okay uh we have the
next iteration of grift from the former
president Donald Trump Donald Trump is
now asking supporters
to donate 45 each in order to quote
solve the election fraud now you might
still be wondering David sir what
election fraud are you talking about
it's still they're still talking about
2020. the non-existent election fraud
from the election almost a year ago
we're like two weeks from a year out
from the 2020 election that's the one
okay here's the letter that Donald Trump
sent
to his supporters this is under the save
America pack
friend did you see what president Trump
said and then it includes the quote from
Trump the statement from Trump from last
week if we don't solve the presidential
election fraud of 2020 Republicans will
not be voting in 2022 or 2024 it is the
single most important thing for
Republicans to do then they pivot to
asking for cash the truth is we need at
least 45 dollars from each Patriot
reading this email each Patriot
if we are going to have the necessary
resources to solve the election fraud of
2020. President Trump is calling on you
to donate to the protect our elections
fund with your help will defend our
elections from the lying left and win
big in 2022 and then again in 2024 and
then a link please contribute at least
forty five dollars or more immediately
to the protect our elections fund now
we've seen this grift before
their advertising hey with a at the low
low price of 45
you can help overthrow the will of the
people because obviously Joe Biden won
in 2020 but it's not even that the goal
is not an admirable goal that it's a
goal based on lies and deception this is
a grift remember when Trump was raising
money with the same type of rhetoric
between November and January 20th or
between November and December 14th and
then January 6th and then January 20th
the money didn't go to recounts the
money didn't go to audits the money
didn't go to fighting election fraud the
money went to Trump to helping Trump pay
off debts that's what it was these
people got scammed it was what we saw
between November and January but then it
didn't stop it's continuing we are a
year out folks if you believe that the
45 dollars you donate to Trump is
actually going to be used to fight
election fraud then you deserve to be
scammed and grifted out of your money
Trump by the way Trump must be in real
trouble financially as we believe him to
be a year out and still milking this
like even for his standards this is a
lot and when we ask Will trump
supporters ever realize there was no
fraud uh probably not
they're gonna believe there was election
fraud for a long time will Trump
supporters ever realize the fraud is
this grifty fundraising being undertaken
by Donald Trump some of them did there
were a couple of big donors to the of
fixed take back the election whatever
fund there were a couple of big donors
back we talked about it earlier in this
year this year who uh sued to get their
money back because they realized that
the money wasn't actually used for that
so some seem to be coming to that
realization but the projection here
seems deliberate right Trump is the guy
who threatens secretaries of state and
said you got to find me the 11 780 votes
he messed with the Postal Service to try
to make it less likely that absentee
ballots would be delivered on time he
incited an Insurrection he extorted
Ukraine for political dirt on his
opponent he filed dozens of frivolous
lawsuits through Rudy Giuliani and these
different lawyers he said stop the
counting here start the counting there
he weaponized covid regarding the
mail-in bowels
he's the guy who tried to steal the
election if there was fraud and
dishonesty it was Trump who did it
but they don't care they are the ones
now being told it was the Democrats that
did it and give me money and I will go
and fix it for you at a certain point
they deserve to be separated from their
money and uh listen the government
shouldn't Step In by their own standards
because that would be the nanny state if
they decide I'm going to donate to this
it's Caveat Emptor right
um and that should be it and many of
these people are falling for it
unfortunately and this really is sad
um a lot of the people donating to these
different funds and sending forty five
dollars they really can't afford it
they're not high income folks uh not
folks with a lot of disposable income
and that that's probably the saddest
part of all of this quite frankly
well we have a voicemail number that
number is 2192 David P call me anytime
here's a teacher who called in during
their lunch break they have a student
who seems to have been the victim of
serious uh political disinformation my
guess would be from the parents take a
listen to this
hi David I teach fifth grade yeah in the
suburbs of Chicago Illinois and I needed
to call you I'm on my lunch break
because right before lunch one of my
students raised his hand I called on him
probably thinking it was a question
about the material or going to the
bathroom something like that sure and in
a straight face said
Joe Biden belongs in prison
and
it I just froze it just froze in the
classroom so
um
just an interesting experience I wanted
to share and maybe get your reaction uh
maybe get your uh
maybe explanation of why well listen my
I I don't know what age this student was
but my guess is
this is not something the student
learned in school but this is probably
something the student is hearing at home
and it's very very sad I mean listen
you come from a conservative family you
might say oh Joe Biden's position on
abortion doesn't align with my families
or whatever
um but Joe Biden belongs in prison
for what crime and that is one of those
signals when you hear that it's sort of
like when you would hear certain things
about said about Barack Obama where you
go that's not a policy disagreement
you've fallen for really serious
weaponized disinformation and it's a sad
thing that it's even hitting uh hitting
kids we've got a great bonus show for
you today we're going to talk about the
Supreme Court backing qualified immunity
for police officers really a big story
with far-reaching trickle-down
implications we will look at Democrats
eyeing a carbon tax a carbon tax after
Joe manchin's opposition to The Climate
plan and the reconciliation bill and we
are going to talk about how Joe Biden is
now trying to figure out how can he
quietly restart student loan payments
and uh why why quietly well I think you
can probably guess why we'll talk about
all of those stories on today's bonus
show get instant access by signing up at
joinpackman.com
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes you can try it for
free and get 25 off a subscription by
going to blinkist.com davidpakman